what if raggedy Anne became a pregnant
man
a poll a survey not a person from Poland
cat found that parents want toys to
educate their children about serious
World issues the survey conducted on
behalf of the Toy Association what the
hell is that found that 63 think toys
should teach kids about bullying 48 said
they should tackle cultural
representation 44 said parents they
should value racial Justice and play
time of course that could be fixed by
giving fewer toys to white kids and one
in six parents rated their own toys when
they were children as poor or fair when
it came to inclusivity and
representation the other five replied
what the hell is wrong with you
but times have changed back in the 80s
Barbie had long hair big boobs short
skirts and hooker heels now it's Ken
his dream house has a back door and a
glory hole
I don't know what that means honestly
says a Toy Association executive with so
many toys that raise awareness about
social issues and other causes like
environmentalism there are countless
opportunities to start a dialogue with
kids on how to create a more caring and
inclusive world
shut your pie hole you big phony I
prefer the good old days when you
learned real life lessons from real toys
for example I learned that pet rocks can
be thrown at Neighbors
[Music]
I learned that Monopoly means you'll
choose money over family
law darts taught me that the human eye
makes a funny sound when it's punctured
as I learned that Weebles wobble but
they won't make your dad come home
I told you that in confidence
laughs
is there anything worse than a woke toy
do you have yeah no there's only thing
worse than a woke toy is a woke Parent
toys aren't going to do your job for you
okay and when you get when you kids get
toys it's imagination time and they're
playing and they're being creative so
the toy is not going to do a job for you
when I was a kid that was like it was GI
Joe and it was Transformers and there
was He-Man and all this stuff and then
all of a sudden they came out with
Captain Planet and teaching you to pick
up litter nobody wanted that toy yeah
nobody wanted born ass Captain Planet
like hey kids you can clean up they were
like kiss my ass I'm not cleaning up I'm
gonna rule the world with Megatron and
it's your imagination stuff but this
goes back to these bulldozer parents who
want the toys to do the job for them you
should be the one speaking to your child
about what's real and what's up and what
affects them not like wow Mr Potato Head
is going to explain to you about the
birds and bees no he's not oh you know
and that's and then shame on these
parents could you imagine a woke Mr
Potato Head
cucumber
I wrote a list yes I renamed all the all
the damn toys okay I got the the woke
names for the new toys how about this
Tickle Me Elmo is now inappropriate
Touch Me Elmo
GI Joe is GN Joe General neutral Joe
Care Bears are now taxpayer-assisted
living bears
Strawberry Shortcake is strawberry
sugar-free gluten-free hormone-free
Shortcake
Teletubbies are teleplus tubbies or
widescreens Transformers are still
Transformers
Malibu Barbie is White Privilege Barbie
uh and Curious George is now by Curious
George
so
you are
the toy industry should hire you well I
got one for Mr Potato Head too because
Tyra's I got Mr Potato Head is now Mr
Potato harvested by exploited
undocumented workers had
[Applause]
a cold burning global warming
contributing train
[Laughter]
cat
did you have any woke toys did you have
any toys as a child I knew that you grew
up in poverty what you played with six
you played with I love playing with
sticks sticks were great dirt I used to
play in the dirt pretend I was one of
The Boxcar Children ah hard to believe
how jealous I was of The Boxcar Children
just because they didn't have a bedtime
they got to solve Miss like I always
wanted to solve Mysteries and I would
put up like our home phone number out in
the neighborhood to be like if you need
any help solving crimes
no one ever did
oh there are a few men who called they
didn't call
um what else did I just used to like
find like frogs and snakes and stuff and
bring them home for a while I was
feeding all these stray cats and I and I
was so sad when they all left and then I
was even more sad like two years ago my
dad admitted that's not exactly what
happened
he sent them to their death
my favorite toy was a jar of bugs yeah
me too I fill up a jar of potato bugs
yeah they just crawl all over each other
and you close it tight just put it on
your desk you just work this is about a
couple years ago like I don't know yeah
back when uh yeah back when the five
started and I would just have my big
thing of bugs that's technically called
a bug orgy bro
yes I wish it was boring
you know I must have I should have
thrown a few spiders in there to spice
things up you know what I'm saying yeah
death camp
guy I think Tyrus is right it's the job
of families to inculcate values that's
fine let the kids enjoy their toys let
it be fun and you can do like lesson
learning a different time and every time
adults feel like they're tricking kids
into learning something through fun it's
usually a failure and the kids realize
that they're being lied to or
manipulated I'm worried that the Toy
Association has gone woke that is fresh
I'm gonna write a book about how to be a
good parent and it's going to be called
imagination not indoctrination I'm gonna
be on the cover like this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that book with that cover could also be
called I just did a silent fart
[Laughter]
we gotta go
don't be woke for one Christmas yeah
that's it and no one buys it they'll be
back there you go all right coming up
holding a briefcase left her scarred
because she always plays the victim card
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else